A question
No one ever asked me
The Room. My favorite movie of all time, is The Room *fake it is actually the chef*
By the man...
The myth...
The legend...
Tommy Wiseau -_-
I can watch this movie infinite amount of times
I never get tired of it *Really?*
Because every time you watch it you find more sh-t that's wrong with it
I mean
You find..
You find more easter eggs
I want this video to convert you
To go and watch this film
I'm gonna link it down below
We don't need another god damn superhero movie
'Cause we already have a superhero
Tommy
Tommy Wiseau
So, why is this movie so great
Well let's start off with one of my  favorite scenes
Just so you get a taste of the movie
Hi
Can I help you?
Yea can I have a thousand red roses please?
Oh hi Johnny I didn't know it was you
Here you go
That's mee
How much is it?
It will be 18 dollars
Here you go, keep the change
HI DOGGY *lol*
You're my favorite costumer
*laughing intensifies*
It feels like watching Marina Joyce in a weird way
Like just TRY TO GET AS MUCH INFORMATION IN THERE AS POSSIBLE
Oh hi I didn't see it was you
Oh hi johnny
Oh you are my favorite costumer
Oh hi doggy *lol*
by-
*laughs*
It's beautiful
It's art
HI DOGGY *lol*
YOU'RE MY FAVORITE COSTUMER
Apparently he didn't see the dog
Until they shot it
So he just all of a sudden added in
Hi doggy *laughs*
HI DOGGY *lol*
YOU'RE MY FAAAAAAAAAAVOOOOOOORIIIIIITEEEE COOOSTUUUUUUUUMEEEEEEER
There are so many culets from this movie
that you can apply to real life
So if you watch this film
I think a lot of my videos will all of a sudden just make sense
The room features; drama
I am going to call the police
Mom stop it was Danny's mistake just stop!
Friendship;
Johnny is my best friend.
love;
ouhhahahaha
action;
How can you be sure, come on Lisa
Just stop asking me stupid questions
Who the hell do you think you are?
JUST SHUT UP! *OHHH B**CH SLAP!*
and, love
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
And... some more love
( ͡°( ͡° ͜ʖ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)ʖ ͡°) ͡°)
And... EVEN MORE LOVE
/╲/\╭( ͡° ͡° ͜ʖ ͡° ͡°)╮/\╱\
MAYBE TOO MANY LOVE SCENES, OKAY? *We get it!*
MAYBE JUST A TINY BIT TOO MANY
The film was made by genius film maker Tommy Wiseau
and you will know this if you watched the movie cause it is mentiones, I do-
HI BABE
Now the story features Tommy, who plays Johnny
His girlfriend, Lisa
I have somethin for uu
WHAT IS IT
And may I say, Lisa is a, *mwah*
smokin hot /╲/\╭( ͡° ͡° ͜ʖ ͡° ͡°)╮/\╱\
You look beautiful today /╲/\╭( ͡° ͡° ͜ʖ ͡° ͡°)╮/\╱\
CAN I KISS U?
Every male character compliments Lisa at some point
in the film
Isn't it FABULOUS?
I will do ANYTHING for my gurl
/╲/\╭( ͡° ͡° ͜ʖ ͡° ͡°)╮/\╱\
Oh hey guys
Oh hi Danny
THE ACTING
THE DELIVERY
THE PASSION
THAT COMES OUT OF TOMMY WI-TO-
The movie also features, one of my favorite characters, Danny
Oh hey guys :)
Danny.
:D
Can I kiss you?
Johnny and Lisa decides to take a..
Take a nap
Nice to see you Danny *But that expression doe*
I'm going to take a nap
(ovo)
I think we both know where this is going..*Oh god no*
*A pillow fight?*
But for SOME reason that..
DANNY COMES IN XD
There is nothing weird about this scene.
TRUST ME -_-
We're just getting started *OML NO*
Danny
Do you have something else to do? *ohhhh*
I just like to watch you guys :)
(Starts laughing)
Awww
Danny
Danny boy~
Danny MUST be some kind of spawn from Satan *OHH*
AnYwAy
We're 5 mins in and it's about to get
SmOkInG I;)
Let's turn up the volume! *WARNING HEADPHONE USERS!*
'Cause the soundtrack...
(MWAH)
It's the best!
YES!! *Eww*
AINSLEY!
YES!
It's beautiful!
You know whenever me and Marzia..You know *Melix shippers are fangirling just like me*
Put on this song *SQUEE*
(Sings the song)
(Laughs)
(Starts singing the song)
Look how happy they are *AWWW*
I have to go now..
Okay
BYE
Bye~
But just like an on and off switch *???*
Emotions can change *DUH*
Lisa is a testimony to that
HI
I don't love Johnny *LISA NO!*
H-HOW?
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?! *IDK PEWDS!*
WHAT HAPPENED BETWEEN NOW AND THEN?
YOU CAN'T
IT JUST DOESN'T
*STOP STUTTERING! GET A LOAD OF YOURSELF!*
Hello?
Hey baby~
How ya doing?
Oh hey how ya doing? Yeah I'm VERY busy, what's going on?
(Sigh I:I)
Now.
Great guest introduced.
Greg of course which is Johnnys best friend!
I'm not gonna put up with that *Jeez*
I'm gonna do what I wanna do and that's it. *BOSSY MUCH?*
What do you think I should do *....Really?!*
(Starts laughing) *IKR PEWDS?*
(Starts clapping) *IKR PEWDS?!*
YES! *So many yes' lately..*
Hey Ainsley..
I wanna do what I wanna do AND THAT'S IT! *Someone's on their period...*
ANYWAY!
Uhh
What do you think I should do?
NO GREG NO!
NOHOHO!
YOU LOVE JOHNNY!!
YOU'RE HIS BEST FRIEND!
NO!
As much as it hurts..
This music makes up for it *WOW*
(Some romance music)
(You witness some fangirls enjoying this moment where Pewdiepie starts singing. DON'T TELL MARZIA!)
Now afterwards there's a line from Greg that I always love
WHY DID YOU DO THIS TO ME?!?
YES! *STOP SAYING YES!*
You had nothing to do w-with it Greg, right?
Tha- I mean you're COMPLETELY innocent, right?
Thanks honey they're BeAuTiFul~ *DON'T DO THIS TO JOHNNY!*
You may think Tommy just looks asleep during all the scenes
But don't worry about it, that's a method acting
That makes..It makes you drawn to his character more
A lot of people don't know how to do it. And that's definitely real fruit btw *SURE*
You're right..
The computer business is too competitive
(Groans)
I know all these lines so much because they're just..THROWN OUT THERE!
The computer business is too competitive
What does that mean? *Idk don't ask us*
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN TO ANYONE?!
DOES SHE WORK IN THE COMPUTER BUSINESS?
WHAT DOES THAT- *STOP ASKING US!(ŌöŌ)*
It's never brought up once again in the movie
But I always appreciate that it's there
There's a lot of open doors in this room *WHAT DOES /THAT/ MEAN?!*
Alright so
They have a drink
They have some fun
annd uhh
We're about 20 mins in *Great*
FOR SEX SCENE NUMBER THREEEEEEEEEEEEEEEE
YEAH! *I'M TELLING MARZIA!*
The music!
It never stops getting good!
(Starts SINING the song. HAHA GET IT?)
Uhh so Lisa's mom
Is uh..Giving her advice throughout what to do with the situation
She doesn't love Johnny anymore *ANYMORE?!*
And she needs some advice
Everything goes wrong at once
Nobody wants to help me..
and I'm dying *Sad*
You're not dying mom
I got the results of the test back
I DEFINITELY have breast cancer *Aww sad*
So she
The mom just drops out of nowhere
That she has breast cancer
And it's never brought up ANYTIME else in the movie
It's just there ôÂô
She has breast cancer
You may think this is just random and stupid
BUT NO!
TOMMY WISEAU
Has...Deeper meaning and
Deep thoughts into it
Alright? It's a movie about many dark twisted themes *oh*
Like cancer *And world hunger*
Now in comes these two f-king characters *This your first time swearing in this video?*
And we have no idea who the f-k they are
But they're in someone else's house
I know what you're thinking *YOU DO?*
'Oh god...
..Oh god, Felix..
another sex scene?!' *DING DING DING!*
Let's have some fun~ ;)
it's getting there..It's definitely getting there
Uh we don't get a sex scene though, However we get the weirdest blow job I have ever seen *OK*
This is arguably one of the greatest scenes of the film
However it's very long and I don't
I don't wanna show too much
I want you guys to watch the movie yourself
Let's just watch a tiny snippet of it
Hey Danny.
Chris R.
I've been looking for ya
This guy is the only person who is not an actor and I do think that he is the best actor in this movie
What do you mean it's coming, Danny? *What's coming?*
Where's. My money *oh*
However, there is one scene that is probably the bets one in this movie
It last for 7 seconds *Like vine? R.I.P*
And it's the best 7 seconds in your god damn life *Prove it*
I did not hit her!
It's not true!
It's bullsh-t!
I did not hit her!
I DID NOT...
Oh hi Mark! *LOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOL*
OH HI MARK!
Apparently
Tom-Tommy
Was having a bit of a rough day when shooting this
and it took a couple of HOURS to get these 7 SECONDS *see the huge difference?*
I'm not
I'm not kidding. It took HOURS *Really?*
I did not hit her!
It's not true!
It's bullsh-t!
I did not hit her!
I DID NOT...
Tommy was struggling to remember the lines
WHICH IS NOT HIS FAULT
Probably
There were people on the set that distracted him *ok*
Oh hi Mark! *LOLOLOLLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOL*
It took that many hours to get that scene is because
other people are unprofessional!
I WANT YOU OFF THE F-KING SET YOU PRICK!
NO DON'T JUST BE SORRY!
THINK FOR ONE F-KING SECOND!
Everyone just got tired after awhile that Greg just gave him a water bottle
'Just throw the water bottle. That will help you get the line.'
And they FINALLY get the shot
And it's
(MWAH)
MAGNIFICENT
I did not hit her!
It's not true!
It's bullsh-t!
I did not hit her!
I DID NOT...
Oh hi Mark! *LOLOLOLOLOLOOLOLOLOLOLOLOLOL*
This is the first Oscar nomination for
TOMMY WISEAU!
You can love someone deep inside your heart..
and there's nothing wrong with it.
If a lot of people love each other...
The world will be a better place to live *True dat*
ART
The movie is so wise
I've learned
Half the decisions I make, I always reference to the room.
I just go from there
So how's Johnny?
I love this scene because
The continuity is a little flawed
I think what REALLY happened here was a glitch
in the Matrix
And the glasses are just teleporting
and it's NOTHING TO DO with Tommy Wiseau
He didn't get his promotion..
Ugh..Is he disappointed?
Quite a bit
Oh now it's in her hand?
We got drunk last night
She's drinking
Now she's picking it up
And he hit me *WOW LIAR*
He hit you?!
He didn't know what he was doing *You little sneaky son of a..*
Now she's drinking
Now she's drinking again! (Are you okay?!)
Well I don't want to marry him anymore
WHAT
She's putting it away!
I found somebody else~
Next time, just skip the glasses
Sex scene number four is....
There's four.
Here's the thing that I love about The Room
compared to other movies that are supposed to be so bad, they're good.
The Room is still somewhat...
Coherent
I mean that
And it has atmosphere *WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?!?!*
It has..
It has something special
Now there's so much more that I can point out
And I....
love this movie so much
but I want you to enjoy it as well
So I HIGHLY recommend you watch it *DO IT*
I'll link to Tommy's website
and where to uh.. Where you can buy the film *DO IT*
and watch it yourself
I HIGHLY recommend it
The reason why I love the movie so much
The movie
and how
and why
it was made is equally interesting
TOMMY WISEAU is such an interesting character
The reason why he wanted to make this
Movie is a movie on it's self
It's a story on it's own
Knowing all the context before watching the film
It makes it even better
If you're intrigued by this video
I HIGHLY recommend that you check it out *HE SAID THIS ABOUT 3 TIMES ALREADY SO DO IT!*
The computer business is very competitive so
I'm gonna have to end this video now
Please do leave a like *DO IT*
And check out this video right here *DO IT! DO EVERYTHING HE SAYS!*
*DOOOOOOOOO IIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIT!*
And I'll see you next time
*BUT WHAT ABOUT THE BRO FISTUUUUU?!*